the champ is here lanier dominguez
showing his tenacity after losing the
first game today still coming back and
winning clear first linear first of all
congratulations on your result
could you have suspected that after
losing today that trend that was going
so well for you after winning four in a
row that maybe had been broken that
you'd be able to still come back and win
clear first without any playoffs yeah it
was really a difficult moment especially
after getting such a nice position from
the opening i think i was playing
uh quite well um
in the opening and i got
i felt that i was just better
maybe i wasn't but anyway
it was a nice position and um to lose
this game was kind of unpleasant and
of course uh from the psychological
point of view uh this uh it was
important not to
um to lose uh my temper that at that
moment and i i
uh knew that i still had chances
and yeah i was i was able to
pull myself together and
keep playing some decent chess
now
how do you do that so quickly you lose a
game there's not much time to think
about it because you've got the next
game coming soon
but how do you get your as you said your
temper right get is there any kind of
trick psychological or otherwise to
breathing meditation anything that you
do or is it just simply
just stop and say everything's gonna be
okay yeah i think it's at least for me
it's uh uh
you you just have to uh
try to get the right uh mindset so i was
i was trying like from the start to not
to think too much about
the result or anything just to take one
game at a time
and uh especially when it's rapid then
of course it's also 960 but when it's
rapid you have to to take it easy and
of course it's it's not always easy to
to manage but uh
but basically i was trying to forget the
game which wasn't easy because you keep
thinking about moves that you missed and
stuff like that but uh yeah i managed on
this on this occasion to just uh forget
and um just uh approach the net the next
game like uh like nothing happened
it's a very strong feel that you played
against here world champion wesley saw
with this format had fabiana caruana
number two in the world it's a deal with
a legend like gary casparov and
everybody paying attention to them none
of us even picked you to win the
tournament by the way slap the
commentators
what how do you contextualize this win
in your great career
yeah it's one of the
one of the best for sure i mean
it's been a long time since i didn't win
win a tournament
this strong
and
it's also nice because uh to win here in
san luis and of course with this super
strong field
it's it's really really nice i mean i
came close a couple of times before um
the us championship in in 2019 i was
second and then and the sink field cup i
was also leading at some point but uh
finally
uh came second so to be able to finally
win a tournament uh uh it's it's really
really great
you came close a couple of times now
you've broken through are you going to
win the u.s championship well that's the
plum let's see how it goes that's the
plan way to go well great performance
here great comeback at the end
congratulations on a fantastic result